bearing sturaro of the present faith
nobel press girin and literature me
had a great honor
will present the Nobel Prize winner
on literature
he loved to play these miracles very much
inle heap
Paradise for Svetlana Aleksievich
I thank the Swedish Academy for the high
the reward that I do not dare to appropriate myself
I understand her as a bow to many generations
Soviet people who recently lived
together in the vast country of the USSR Mars sky
bright future laboratories
how to bow with their suffering their pain and they
went into oblivion of the Stalinist camps on
the mines of the magician of this Vorkuta got a bullet
in the back of the dungeons of the NKVD perished
fronts of world war two friend and
other wars that led the empire
a great idea ruthlessly devoured its
children ideas do not hurt people feel sorry
are like the site has you see academy for
10 cm will be here because one will remove the smile
or he radar
and sit in the subway mini generations
not silvara on midu swan hitler and not
Maxis for curb approves futu
give a blow to the end of the code jess here here we have
our safari
yes and dozens of tape become
not stalinist keeps in da mainc with
thankful to vorkuta
will complete and dpk runs and do not stick up chambers
dna and paris and dc ken courtyard
n and d wars empire for the great
keyboard is in children with out mass
feel sorry
for keyboard restructuring we dreamed of
freedom turned out to be a completely different point
stories in the post-Soviet space
instead of freedom 1
y of totalitarianism of various colors Russian
Belarusian Kazakh slowly and
uncertainly
getting out from under the rubble red
empire is one of the heroines of my book time
suck on hand whose whole family was
sent to Siberia and died there with
shed tears in our eyes as we sat by
her in the kitchen
morning paints with gentle light the walls of the ancient
Kremlin wakes up at dawn all
soviet land is mighty mighty some
invincible country my Moscow my
you are the favorite Yuri perestroika
you days of freedom baty founders of
it and a years old different countries to
lie in da house council era instead of
freedom wars stripes
imprinted talen from from but only rush in
belarus
Russian Cossack you are fine day a way out
from an de de de de de merged
my boobs and hand
time
Harry Sevoyan us and her family was x
altis I killed end ah yes
light and Nikitin for hours without settling
in tone but there are also as many things
in the stroller d-da kremlin installed in
circles
and have space is served tapes vikings you
dodon ex-yu brand and make in win 7 of
capitals mckenzie miles davis timokhova
the past did not let her out
hugs and and taught to believe her still
that girl lived with Stalin
once took all
she still believed in what to the flock
bottom rummaged arrange frida beasts
embrace her bandages loved
tallit olga rambue steel nuance here
Eugeny shot inside in 6 hryvnia
Here is game drank
I want to tell about my country Belarusians
in Minsk when Europort or the body of Warsaw
two young girls came up to me they
cried thank you understand and we now
now everyone knows where is Belarus
thank you I give to all of you after
orlovsky mail
ninety-first year when belarus
gained independence has grown
several generations of each of them
had their own revolution they were going out on
the square they wanted to live free country
they were beaten and sent to prison
expelled from the institute dismissed from work
our revolution did not win
but the heroes of the revolution we have a race
currents bold mike g
Belarus chudin you mines and whips and on
Minsk and yanao you he my drink you
diver edge santa 10 you understand
on and revealed exist
on and he was put to belarus from
but kan babys thank you to all over
several generations
Abdul on since pelorus so independent
of the abyss nike nike jar and man
from the revolution chair
askom out on the desk with the demons
hide and i chose won anything
in a free also i am albin by then
sends the present hryvnia out of
groups and fires from the jobs
auras blues in as not in pictures at
saw
heroes freedom is not fast idle
how we dreamed this way a long way
now we know that freedom is not an
instant tennis holiday
it is war
we all live in a common world he is called
the earth in this world of ours has become uncomfortable
turn on the TV and there choking
from delight announcer talks about new
military aircraft of the ship in Russian
English and other languages
again the era of barbarism era
the power of democracy retreats is remembered
90s
then it seemed to all of us and to you and to us that
we stepped into the safe world i remember
Gorbachev's dialogues with the Dalai Lama
about the future about the end of the story today all
it seems like a beautiful fairy tale now we
witnesses
new fight good and evil witnesses and
participants viola endo symbol
these how I am
Auers uah an ussr our website
if robinho drive your cats paints in your
en america
ellen and dakine jess or vadis will give
era of and carried the vans era of power team
an orange from the game of street athens almost to
all.biz
it was that it became them to you as the
quiet and safe guard ohio mn Gorbachev
would give dalai lama
bad steel and steel
history miracle goes 07 sweet and orbit
autumn beach
i love you
mrs
almost 5 what can art aim
arts accumulate person in
man but when i was at war in
afghanistan and now when i'm talking
in Ukraine with refugees from the Donbass I
I heard how quickly a man flies
culture and creep out monster is exposed
beast but i write keep writing
I write how my teachers taught me
Belarusian writers Ales Adamovich and
vasil bulls which on this day I
would like to remember with gratitude how
taught my Ukrainian grandmother who
childhood I read the kobzar Taras
Shevchenko by heart
I write why he calls me a writer
disasters it's not true I'm still
words of love are not on the leaf will not save us
only love will save us
tea and accomplish the path is too late to
you mine 1 1 month
They bug when a vos and on focal steel
yuriy up advice to inviz and speaking
there without go nuts and new game hub bought
6 alpha monster inter and matiz
before biysk if there is
ayrat oh continue to write a and wright
syros that catch and hour of Belarus
nereides ales adamovich
vasyl boyko and godfather mnb throw you spend
air with my maid of honor Mr. model that
Minsk here is less site
was it from the front a simple piece
Kobzar d-pad Tyumen
michael airat and i bin kol rights of the
stories that is in time
al weiss hatch cage rite
not so i was love and hate
for pardon would like to in this
the beautiful hall sounded Belarusian
rivers speech of my people or
miracle yandex money fist and had a wood
like you made by bergen rushen
sound tallin be in fry at one
Belarusian weight watches old woman
carried me by words thin to us
break up with you
have different tanks wild i mean and you
listened to me and carry my cleaning
people ask you
if you go and look at my hut
look back and not one but two times the other 1
man for milked not by someone else's qi but already
a heart
i want to thank you for your heart
for hearing our pain
Jan van tire dealer 902 mind baby flower
where we pour the waltz Suva in the ice
sugar is from tanks or Tyumen themselves
heart attack may paint theodore peter i
get you as you lied you love may little
100 Evans from PMS War songs of luxury
Saken time it is not ed.
And I about you trend and teslyuk
exhale and goodnight kiss and you all for
listen to over your hat on for scene
again